FAST AS OTHER STATES.
>> Tucker: FINALLY SOME GOOD
NEWS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
LAST NIGHT, WE SHOWED YOU THE
VIDEO, AND IT WAS NAUSEATING, OF
SENIOR WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION
OFFICIALS OF BRUXELLES WARD
REFUSING TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
ABOUT TAIWAN AND HOW IT WAS
DEALING WITH CORONAVIRUS.
IN FACT, HOWARD WOULDN’T EVEN
ACKNOWLEDGE THE QUESTION OR THE
EXISTENCE OF TAIWAN.
IT WAS REPULSIVE.
BUT IT WASN’T SURPRISING, HE WAS
JUST FOLLOWING DIRECTIONS FROM
THE VERY TOP.
TETRIS ON THEM WHO IS THE
DIRECTOR OF THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION GOT HIS JOB WITH
CHINA SUPPORT AFTER HE
COVERED UP COLOR OUTBREAKS IN
HIS HOME COUNTRY, THE PERFECT
MAN TO LEAD THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION AND HE HAS
SUBSEQUENTLY SET THE STANDARD
FOR CORRUPTION.
HERE HE IS IN JANUARY.
WATCH THIS.
>> THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT SHOULD
BE CONGRATULATED FOR THE
EXTRAORDINARY MEASURES IT HAS
TAKEN TO CONTAIN THE OUTBREAK.
THE SPEED WITH WHICH CHINA
DETECTED THE OUTBREAK ISOLATED
THE VIRUS, AND SHARED IT WITH
W.H.O. IN, THE WORD IS VERY
IMPRESSIVE.
CHINA IS SETTING A NEW STANDARD
FOR OUTBREAK RESPONSE AND THAT’S
NOT AN EXAGGERATION.
>> Tucker: THAT’S THE TOP
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIAL IN THE
WORLD AND EVERYTHING YOU JUST
HEARD HIM SAY THERE WAS A LIE.
A RECENT 60 MINUTES PIECE FROM
AUSTRALIA, A PIECE THAT OUR
MEDIA ARE NOT PLAYING SHOWS JUST
HOW DEEP THE LIES GO.
IN FACT, THERE IS NOTHING SPEEDY
ABOUT HOW CHINA DETECTED THE
OUTBREAK AND WARNED THE WORLD.
INDEED, THEY DID THE EXACT
OPPOSITE.
>> FROM THE VERY BEGINNING
THROUGHOUT DECEMBER IT WAS
SPREADING AND WE NOW KNOW IT WAS
SPREADING HUMAN TO HUMAN.
BUT THE OFFICIAL LINE OF THE
CHINESE GOVERNMENT WAS THIS WAS
ALL RELATED TO AN ANIMAL MARKET
AND WANTS TO CLOSE THE MARKET IT
WOULD ALL GO AWAY.
>> DID THEY KNOW DIFFERENTLY AT
THAT TIME?
ABSOLUTELY.
BECAUSE THEY WERE SEEING CASES
COMING INTO THE HOSPITALS THAT
HAD NOTHING WHATSOEVER TO DO
WITH THAT ANIMAL MARKET.
>> Tucker: SO THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION’S LEADERSHIP TELLS
YOU THAT CHINA "SET THE STANDARD
TO THE OUTBREAK RESPONSE WHICH
INCLUDES DISAPPEARING DOCTORS
WHO TELL THE TRUTH ABOUT IT.
>> IS CHINA NOW TRIES TO REWRITE
HISTORY AND CLAIM IT WAS
TRANSPARENT ALL ALONG, A FINAL
NAIL IN THE COFFIN AS THEY LIE.
TWO WEEKS AGO THE HEAD OF
EMERGENCY AT ROUEN CENTRAL
HOSPITAL ALSO WENT PUBLIC SAYING
AUTHORITIES HAD STOPPED HER AND
HER COLLEAGUES FROM WARNING
THE WORLD.
SHE HAS NOW DISAPPEARED,
WHEREABOUTS UNKNOWN.
>> Tucker: AGAIN.
WHY IS IT LEFT TO AUSTRALIAN
MEDIA TO PRODUCE A PIECE LIKE
THIS?
THE TRUTH IS A 60 MINUTES
AUSTRALIA EXPLAINS, INSTEAD OF
WORRYING ABOUT THESE DEPONENTS,
IN EARLY FEBRUARY THE DIRECTOR
OF THE WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION
WAS STILL LECTURING THE PUBLIC
THAT USING TERMS LIKE THE WUHAN
BYVIRUS WAS INAPPROPRIATE.
>> THEY ARE USING OTHER NAMES
THAT CAN BE INACCURATE OR
STIGMATIZING.
>> Tucker: YOU MIGHT THINK
THAT THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION, A GROUP THAT GOT
50 MILLION OF YOUR TAX DOLLARS
LAST YEAR MIGHT CARE THAT A
GOVERNMENT ARREST DOCTORS AND
LIES ABOUT DEADLY NEW DISEASES.
BUT NO.
LIKE SO MANY ORGANIZATIONS THEY